i want to thank our sponsor liquid death
they are a company and they do good
water
asheville north carolina i want to let
you know that we have tickets going on
sale for you
part of the return of the rat tour can't
even pronounce my own tour damn bro
failure
you're a piece of [ __ ] kid
um it's at the orange peel
that's where it will be tickets go on
sale tomorrow morning at 10 a.m eastern
the show will be october 24th also
tickets are sold out in most places
except for uh this weekend in durham
north carolina there's a few tickets
left
uh for the 9 26 show september 26th
september 30th in chattanooga
at the tavoli
uh
october 2nd knoxville october 9th
wilkes-barre
october uh 14th minneapolis october 23rd
charleston
november 10th burlington and november
11th albany albany
albany new york
uh all those at theovan.comtour um
let's get into the episode
take a breath baby
when i was young they would say take a
breath they'd come and they'd hold your
lungs while you're breathing
the doctor
and he put that big cold stethoscope on
your back
we had a dude in our neighborhood who
said he was a doctor he'd come he had a
cold ear one of his ears he didn't have
a lot of blood flow to it and he put
that [ __ ] right on your uh back
and he said he said he was a doctor and
i think
dude probably pedophile pediaphile
whatever
pedia i think is children
but damn
you know
[Music]
mr rice this fella hit you with that
cold ear boy he put that co
mom would take you over there she didn't
you didn't know he said he was a doctor
nobody was saying they were a doctor
back then
nobody was
you know
and he had some type of get up it looked
like a doctor's outfit
could have been a damn
halloween costume i don't know i didn't
know him that well i was a child
but i remember we go over there and he
put that blood that one of his ears
didn't get a lot of blood flow on it
i think it was the right one
and he'd put that [ __ ] on your back or
your front
listen to your heart
i went i remember one time whenever that
was probably about 9 10
dude listening part of my ass a little i
said
this is really
this seems
outside of
the medical realm you know i'm saying
this dude probably
where where's his office why are we at
the park
why are we at the park mom for this
doctor
so
there's all different types of docs out
there i guess but
uh
i don't know what i was talking about
anyway a lot of bad doctors out there is
what i'm trying to say a lot of false
gods baby
you know and um
anyway i'm happy to be here with you
today
uh
you know i know i'm um i'm happy to be
here with you today just we got a great
new song by evan bartels
and he he he played that song the devil
god in me for us a while back
and we're going to close out with one of
his new songs today
what happened what have i been doing oh
i was in uh i hit the road
i hit the road man we had a good time we
started out there in peoria illinois
out there not far my mother's from not
far from there
and she's an adult now but she was a
child at one point
and um
[Music]
just a hard working area pretty simple
area
so we went over there to peoria
and uh
it's a little dicey a little dicey but
um
but we had a great time a lot of nice
people came out we did two shows there
starting the starting off the new tour
return of the rat tour
and kind of got the pieces put together
we went combining we got in a corn
combine and got to go cut corn boy
this fella brandon and his brother i
think his brother
i don't know if he's well or not i don't
who know who knows who's well but he
decent both of them decent men and
they took us out there riding they just
we met them and they wrote us in their
combine and the corn cutter damn
beautiful
beautiful young fellas i thought they
were lovers they said they're brothers i
said now
i bet if we turn our back you'll be more
than brothers you know what i'm saying
but anyway
they were nice they seemed like nice
guys they took us riding out there
and it's just wild to think
that you're riding through corn you're
riding through damn cornbread
you're riding through uh
frosted flakes
you're just crazy you're just cutting it
all down
just making cornmeal
corn dogs
uh
corn flakes corn
uh candy corn
just shooting out the back
i wish the tractor the cutter actually
had a um
little corn popper in it
and they just fed some kernels into
there you pressed butter on that [ __ ]
or double butter you know what i'm
saying boy
too much double butter you're gonna have
that cold ear against your back but you
have some pediophile
out there hitting you with that cold ear
on your spinal column dude trying to
touch ass in a park son
anyway whatever good parenting but what
i'm telling you is this um
we had a nice time over there and we
took a day off just to be human and be
out there
and that's all i am is human you know
that's all any of us are
a lot of expectation out there
but all i am is human we had a beautiful
time we went fishing over there
i got a buddy a friend of mine uh it's
my brother's good friend named danny
big danny they call him
and he really he looks just like um
peter's wife from family guy
and i say that i love beautiful man
and he took us out there we went fishing
caught some fish and
they do asphalt they took the day off
and met us and him and his children we
went fishing
and it was a nice time and
that was out in toulon illinois i think
anyway we hit some some small some small
areas uh and then what did we do
oh we rode over to
st louis
let me hit this liquid death for a
little bit before i tell you about that
ah liquid death
oh and liquid death i will tell you this
dead till death is streaming now on
amazon
from the creators of mr pickles and
concrete cowboy comes the story of a
group of friends who leave the city to
camp in the woods and eat mushrooms
dead till death is now streaming on
amazon prime and i think it's based on
liquid death or has in it liquid death
is in it
them kids are drinking liquid death
oh
so then we hit saint louis i got to
throw out the first pitch
and we stopped along the way and
practiced pitching because look i'm not
a pitcher
you know what i'm saying i throw a bunch
of i throw rocks sometimes i'll throw
rocks if i'm skipping rocks
um
i'll throw shade at a [ __ ] you feel me
uh
i throw something away sometimes
sometimes i throw in the recycler
sometimes i don't you know say boy
dude i'll take a 800 pack of loose leaf
and put that batch right in the trash if
i'm
really honest with you okay
if i'm really really honest now if you
want me to put my cold ear to your back
and tell you something else
tell you got measles i can do it but i'm
not doing that
this this was beautiful man and uh
shout out stubbles clap dude the guy
he's a beautiful guy
he's a uh
first base coach for the saint louis
cardinals
and they got a set up over there to
throw out the first pitch him and this
lady named emily
and i'm grateful to them
bush stadium man i didn't realize when
you go to a baseball field you go down
on the field
and man the grass it is
it is like a
i'm it looks like a barber has been out
there all night
you know it looked like somebody's been
out there with just manscaping the yard
i mean this thing looked
this they just everything was there the
side burns and the
the outfit every there was just this
light kind of gradient it just all damn
it was beautiful
oh
made you want to look in your own ass
kind of place you know what i'm saying
that kind of deal but um yeah so that
was really dude and then you get out
there they had a nice jersey for me
little rat king hitter out there
and i got up dude and uh
and the ball i threw it was a good pitch
you know we stopped in a few places in
practice it was a good pitch it was just
on the outside of the box just
on the cusp
so
but
but it was a good it was it was
unbelievable man just to be out there
man
[Music]
play ball
reminding me of my days out there on the
playville cubs and a lot of people know
that i played for playville cubs
some of our team probably died i think
a couple overdoses and
a couple underdosers couple people that
never did any drugs but just died anyway
and
we played it out there on the american
legion field as we were children and
the field was damn slanted dude so every
ball went to damn third every ball went
to left field really eventually
you gave it long enough you set a
stopwatch in 40 seconds a damn a bunt
would be in left field
it was just that this the the setup it
was just we dude we had six people
playing left field
and they put me on him right
and it was just it was dicey dude
i've told that story playbill cubs or
clubs some of our jerseys said cubs some
set clubs on them a couple of damn
misprints on them dude
beautiful brother
but
what else man a lot of great stuff then
we went uh over to cincinnati we played
at the pageant
i want to apologize for anybody those
shows were loud man the just people were
it was just a it was like it's like a
big bar in there
and if you've been to a bar you know
there's things happening people's
touching titty people's you know
people's texting the babysitter
you see a dude there with his wife he's
dick picking the babysitter
sending her little freaking meat jpegs
you know
this dude's over there he's jpegging
meat over to the freaking
babysitter he's like dude what your
wife's right here
he's like she's got popcorn she's fine
like all right
do what you guys do
um
but yeah still a lot people came out
they were excited man the excitement was
there cincinnati we got to this place
the icon theater
and it never had a performance and it
had been unperformed in
for comedy it had maybe five rock and
roll shows
um
a couple country music shows i think but
then we got there and we did uh
we did comedy
and man that was really really sick dude
that was sick
it was about 2300 we had two shows and
it was just like this beautiful kind of
it kind of has like a part it had like a
part like a really
it looked like a futuristic parking
garage with nice seating
in it
um
and it was just
man just thank you
thank you to everybody that that uh that
came out and
and just helped us fig you know it's
weird like taking
letting go of some of the old jokes and
trying the new and being brave enough
you know
are they gonna like them
are they gonna like me
you know
so on a couple of the shows i felt like
wonders i felt like all the shows were
good i felt like one or two or maybe a
little better than the others but that's
just it could also be in my head
i had some people tell me they thought
the new tour was better than the old
tour and they'd seen that a couple times
and there was still a little crossover
between the two so
but anyway man it was just awesome man
thank you for making my dreams come true
i really i really do appreciate that
and i want you guys to keep hitting the
hotline let me know who's listening to
the show what do you do
what do you care about
what scares you hit me 985-664-9503
a lot of unique things uh
happened man
and i wanna say we started the show in
peoria because there used to be a term
if it'll play in peoria
you know a lot of vaudeville acts and
[Music]
you know different type of
you know vaudeville used to be a real
it was people on the run from the law it
was
you know perverts and some musicians but
a lot of somebody one dude get up there
and just you know play with his wiener
for an hour and he drew a g note on his
nuts or something people like what is
this guy doing
you know
so
it just you know it's a lot it used to
be vaudeville was a way to you know you
could do a crime and then next thing you
know you tell people you juggle and
you're traveling the universe juggling
but there was a term if it would play in
peoria it would play anywhere
and um
and so that's one of the reasons kind of
we started over there i wanted to just
have a real
small town vibe i wanted to have a and
it's not a small town it's a small city
and it's a beautiful little city
i was really impressed man i hadn't been
there in a while and
i spent one halloween there and i saw uh
some dude in blackface actually
uh
i don't want to say beat up but
abused a mermaid by a um
hot dog cart
and that was it halloween and you know
that's what
what are we gonna do now you know it was
probably seven eight years and eleven
years ago maybe but
and everybody would nobody died it was
and she got some shots in you know i'm
saying that [ __ ] was finned up so
you know it is what it is and that's how
it all shook out but anyway uh
what are we talking about man
but then yeah cincinnati thank you it
was just amazing i just can't believe
that many people came out and care about
the show and uh and want to be a part of
my life and it just i don't know if i
tell you guys enough how much it means
to me so thank you so much uh and i love
you
i really do
if i could just take my heart and just
cut into
different pieces i i i'd mail you one
you know i'm saying or i give one of
your son or your child
put it in his little lunch box
um
dude my mom used to we used to have to
make our own lunches for summer camp and
the worst thing that happened
the worst
you'd make the thing you'd put the
cooler in there with a little kool-aid
that was it making our kool-aid
sometimes it was too strong he had that
that [ __ ] what they would just make it
damn
it would make your [ __ ] neck retract
you'd look like a turtle and
you know for the second half of the
afternoon
you couldn't even play hide and go seek
because you couldn't look around but
your neck was if you if you made that
kool-aid powder too strong
because when i was young you had to get
the powder and get the water you had to
do a little bit of science baby
now it comes pre-packaged it's all done
for you
when i was young you had to do a little
bit of the work
and i'd make my lunch i put the kool-aid
get the thermos then the thermos had a
little lid on it that you could
use you would take the lid off and drink
out of the lid a little cup
like you worked at a factory or
something it's like [ __ ]
this ymca summer camp
okay and most of the counselors dude are
you know work at the bank so let's be
realistic about what's going on here
we're not doing any sheet metal out here
um
but the worst thing that happened was
my sandwich i gave me a little sandwich
usually peanut butter and jelly
sometimes honestly
double peanut butter
i go no jelly bro
sometimes i go no jelly
and my sisters i know we get mad we make
our sandwiches
sometimes i would come down before we
made them
i would get extra peanut butter put it
on the inside of the jelly jar
then i would
have them just think i was doing jelly
because that's where i live i lived in a
place where every freaking ounce was
accounted for
we had a lot of you know
accounted for ounces baby that's where
we were
and where am i now
i'm upstairs
you know that
you know that son
but at the time i was
it was a counted four ounces baby my
sisters would the second the spoon went
in there every other kid that other kids
would look over i'm like what are you do
how much how much you getting
how much are you mom look at me how much
you get
how much are you getting
so you had to sneak you had to be tacked
a cow baby it'd be tactical
uh anyway enough about me man i want to
know more about you guys we got a lot of
beautiful questions that have come in
today we got a call in a little while
with this fella named chad who was uh
a a really best friend of uh billy
conforto
and so
man
excuse me man we are so blessed to be
able to speak with him for a few minutes
and
um
you know that's just god working in our
lives man
and letting billy come back to us all
right let's get into the episode man we
got a lot of great stuff we're going to
uh man a lot of wonderful calls and
appreciated that i want to let you know
first and foremost though that we got to
pay the bills
and i'd appreciate your help you know
some podcast ads take up time
that's the truth
and others they save you money
well this one can save you hundreds no
matter where you live or what you drive
if you drive vehicle hell if you drive
horse
everyone has to have car and home
insurance or horse insurance
but comparing insurance companies isn't
how you like to spend your time it's a
bummer you call over there lance's
insurance you say hey lance what do you
know you cover a boat
like well we don't cover boats we cover
floods
you're like well what if my what if
there's a flood my house turns into a
damn boat
you're like well you're screwed at that
point
see a lot of a lot of trickery and
chicanery within it all
but the zebra
they can help
you know i've had my i've had my issues
with insurance i really was spending an
extra uh
i was spending an extra probably
211 a month maybe 212 dollars a month
wasted down the drain
down the drain
not anymore
i did some configuring and
a little flagellating bro
did a little
you know
cunnilingus or whatever you do on the
computer and did it and the zebra they
do it for you they compare car and home
insurance quotes from every major
insurance company that's right just
check it out
you got 10 minutes check it out figure
it out
maybe you save six seven hundred
buy you buy your kid a floaty toy for
the pool
or if you're in a flooding area by you
buy your damn wife a damn
neck brace or something inflatable neck
brass
what i'm saying is support the podcast
as well compare the quotes for free at
the zebra.com
slash t-h-e-o that's the zebra.com theo
thank you for your support
now speaking of support
everybody wiener bad out there
and you know what i'm talking about bad
dick
bad
everybody weiner bad
if you walked into a classroom my winter
be in the corner with a dunce cap on son
my winter being time out
because people weiners ain't working
anymore
because we've drifted away from the
thing that make us men and that make us
virile and viral and viral
one of them
that's why blue chew's here to help
get that dick snack baby you know what
i'm saying get that dick snack
blue chew is an online prescription
service no visits to the doctor's office
no awkward conversations no waiting in
line at the pharmacy none of that
it's actually really simple i've done it
i've called
i said hey
give daddy them nick hitters
i've called and got a batch man they
come every month you got too many of
them now
i gave them one of them to a damn 17
year old the other day dropped him off
man hey bubby
get out there son
get out there and back clean up over
there but anyway do what you can that's
all i'm saying blue chew will help
blue chew
tablets are made in the usa no foreign
tablets
everybody knows i bought some of them
indian tablets that make my legs sweat
penis hard but legs sweating
that's not what i want i want dry legs
good dick
and i'm sorry for using the d word so
much i know there's a lot of
uh females that listen and i'm sorry
about it you know i'm feeling some type
of way today and i'm
just trying to get through the day i'm
just human
anyhow here's a special deal for our
listeners try blue chew for free when
you use our promo code theo at checkout
just pay five dollar shipping that's
b-l-u-e-c-h-e-w
dot com promo code t-h-e-o to receive
your first month free and we thank blue
chew for sponsoring the podcast yes we
do um
here we go right here we got a call that
came in right here and uh
let's
get into it
hey i'm calling you live from the shower
uh just for full consent sake i am new i
shall ruin them
okay nude boy we got a nude fella out
there
you know what i'm saying man this dude
will put his ear to your back you know
what i'm saying i do run in that fake
hospital
gang baby let's go come on
and uh i'm not just moved man i'm angry
a little angry maybe you can believe
that because i'm thinking uh
you should have had norm mcdonald on
your show man
gosh it's like that's a good that might
be the great tragedy of some comedy of
this generation you and him none of
these are you guys played by rules
and he got five from snl that you
wouldn't play they specifically said
don't make these kind of jokes and he
said okay one second he did that joke
immediately and i know that's you
so uh i don't know man i hope you talked
about norm on your next episode and
youtube guys
you know he was and you are
that great bizarre dark sensation
thank you brother and i didn't mean to
cut you off man but i think the shot he
got a little showery hard to hear you
for a second but i i feel your sentiment
and thank you
for sending in the question to be naked
and call another man is a it's a
that's a choice
and i appreciate you
here's one thing man it is really sad
about norm
and i'll tell you why i felt like it's
the most sad
you know i texted adam he get i texted
david spade people that i knew that knew
him decently
you know norm had been a recluse for a
while
you know he'd really been one of those
whatever it is that boston spider or
whatever the thing that bites people or
something
it gets
you know a lot of court-ordered
separation
or whatever i don't that's boston i
don't know i think i'm mixing things up
but a lot of dudes in boston have
restraining orders that's what i'm
saying
separately what i'm saying is that norm
was uh
he kind of stayed away from people it
seemed like to me
we reached out to him to have him on
i think there was some discussion about
it for a bit uh between him and nick
davis or his producer and nick davis uh
but
never made it happen i didn't know he
was struggling so bad i didn't hear even
that he was
[Music]
the saddest part about it is that or to
me this is all just to me
and i'm just a human
uh
there's not a lot of comedians out there
there's not a lot of us
there's a little bit of comedian in all
of us
and i think
there's not a lot of comedians out there
though and so when you lose one of them
and not to mention one of the greats and
one of the last ones
that would speak his mind
it feels like you're losing a book
that nobody has copies of of
that's what it feels like i think
especially with norm like he
when you go watch him back on that joy
behar show or the one like the view
and he's just giving those [ __ ]
chubby thoughts the what for
you can just see they're all afraid to
speak anything that's not written on the
script from the producers and he's just
doing what he wants
and he stays there and he's got the joy
of just a mark norman the whole time
just this childhood fever that they
can't even fight
with their freaking money grubbing trap
house
uh
um
soulless
uh
just lack it's not even comedy what any
of them do
it's not even and he shows up and just
toes they're like you're never gonna be
back and he's like
go watch that clip if you haven't we'll
put it in the clips that's a special
clip but the sad thing is there's not a
lot of comedians to when you lose one
not to mention one of the greats
and one of the rarest types
and i really say this as a famine i
don't even i mean i am a comedian but i
don't know if i feel like that sometimes
you know norm was from just a different
ilk
to be so sick and not even publicize it
but to be like imagine you go to the zoo
and they got like a white tiger in there
you know or white llama or whatever
and that [ __ ] hides away you know
everybody the kids come they're spitting
in each other's mouths trying to pretend
like they're the alarm or spitting in
each other's eyes you know eating
[ __ ] llama you know llama
you know
little llama dogs or whatever
you know just
just some some thick kids over there
just double llama dogging little
tiffany's over there
and she's gonna have trouble on junior
high i know that
but you know what i'm saying man uh
yeah
yeah it's just heartbreaking i'll tell
you a good normal story so
the only one i really have
so
norm and i are doing a show in shawnee
oklahoma
at a casino and
there's an interesting group of people
there
you know it's a lot of d-list
celebrities like ourselves
um
it's a lot of oh the guy
from american idols pants on the ground
johnny or whatever it is jerry black
jerry
black jerry's there he's pulling his
pants up and down and up and down i
think his legs almost came at one point
his pants had just crossed over him so
much
but anyway this dude's in the lobby he's
got his pants up he's got his pants
danny's got his just [ __ ] he's got an
extra he got a pants and a bag next to
him just people throwing pants on he
doesn't even know you know it's just
pants and it just
oh just pants pants pants this [ __ ]
guy you remember him golden jerry or
whatever it is black golden jerry dark
jerry chocolate jerry or something the
singer
looking like a fool with my pants on the
ground you know what i'm saying vinny
okay the show ran late because he
brought his girlfriend out
okay
like tits in the [ __ ] wild
johnetta or something
so he's like look i love you cause i
think he had to do a certain amount of
time he brought her out and then he
repeated tits on the tits on the side
tits on the tits on the ground i don't
know what it was this [ __ ] i don't
even know this [ __ ] got a briefcase
full of tits i don't know what's going
on okay i'm upstairs baby
i'm not downstairs dealing with the [ __ ]
hell is this
so anyway i'm up there and uh finally
it's my turn to go on and because
there's a comedy show the night before
there's a poker game the next day
so this is the comedy show i'm opening
up for norman
norm sorry
i'm sorry mr mcdonald
norm
well i went over i was trying to prove
myself i think i was i felt
probably some sense of entitlement or i
just went over i don't know
i'm not a big light runner or
i don't know i have my moments i'm not
like a black guy
black guy run the light two and a half
hours
and that's not even a red that ask
anybody
that's what they do
so anyway i uh i'm running i'm black guy
i'm up there black guy i'm going long
adam eager is there with norm who i
didn't even know at the time
who would turn out to be the booker at
the comedy store and one of my closest
friends actually
and i love you adam if you hear this
just know i love you
um
and i'm sorry you lost your buddy
anyway so i go long and i think i don't
know if this is true norm liked to have
a pill every now and then okay i think
anyway i could
i'm pretty sure i i'm pretty sure i
think anyway i don't know if he'd had a
pill and then he
and who doesn't have a pill
let me start there
i'm not trying to shame norm at all and
i want to say that
i got some type i'm sure if you look at
my antidepressant whatever the thing the
hair there's something in my system
right now i i don't know anybody in
there who's not on something okay
if you've had two mangoes this morning
[ __ ] you [ __ ] jungled up you know
what i'm saying we all got something
going
so anyway
no by the time i ran late so i think
norman kind of maybe if he had taken any
pills he had scheduled the medication to
kind of take effect at a certain moment
i get up there and i went long so i
think his the medicine had kind of maybe
started to come in a little early or may
he was i don't know
but he gets up there dude and he's not
using
he wasn't using the whole alphabet okay
he was going real just
it was like a lot of vowels only a
couple
um
anyway
you know uh it was a great show and the
next morning and adam eager was like
this [ __ ] at me just because i
ran late and i don't blame him you know
which would make it years later when i
got to the comedy store it would make it
tough for me to get in there and i
didn't know that at a time bro i never
knew anything at the time and i still
don't know anything
if you frisked me for knowledge bro
you'd be feeling a lot you'd be feeling
for a
you'd be feeling somebody bust you for
uh for feeling somebody before they
you'd bless me
for having knowledge
point brain
baby praise god so anyway so the next
one uh the next morning i'm downstairs
it's a poker tournament
jerry mathers is there the beaver
and jerry mathers as the beef he's there
i go say i'm sorry to norm
norm's looking around the room
a lot of chicks in there not really a
lot there's a couple chicks and
that dudes in there with bigger tits
than women it's [ __ ] oklahoma
people's thick people's double bone you
got a dude in there with nine shoulders
you got a dude selling [ __ ]
uh
selling meat right off his own body you
know you go to some of those middle
eastern shops and they're just cutting
meat right off the thing this dude's
doing that right off his arm
just right off of just chopping it right
onto a damn bread
people's over there buying meat off you
know people to buying
damn pack of six subs right off this
dude's tricep
so anyway man we got it going
everybody's doing decent and uh
and i go over to norm i apologize and uh
he goes man there's a lot of hot
[ __ ] in here isn't there
and i'm looking around the room and
there isn't
there is not
there there was not
but i i think he's serious you know so
i'm just like i'm like oh here's a guy's
a little bit older yeah
so i say yeah man sure is a lot of
hotties in here
and he goes the [ __ ] there are
and it just [ __ ]
man it took me to another level because
here i am thinking i'm placating this
guy's a little bit older than me
make him think yeah these chicks are hot
man i'm going to agree with you yeah bud
a lot of hotties in here
and the whole time he knew he knew he
was older than me he knew that i was
thinking he thought these women were hot
and uh
and there it was
you know
he had his own
you know some humor is a maze i
think in some comedians they make it's a
maze
it's a maze that
sits between them and the world
and the way
that the humor is created is
is that some people have such a unique
maze something people would set up punch
that's a small maze setup punch
some people it's the element of surprise
some people it's
it's just extremely direct and dry
but i think norm just had a his maze was
just different
and i don't think you can create that i
think it's built into you
and uh
yeah one of a kind man
and he had a great quote too about uh
cancer
he said cancer doesn't i think it was
him
i don't know people have been saying it
was him that
if cancer doesn't beat you because when
you die it dies at the same time so
technically
it's a draw
let me get this right
um
[Music]
yeah
norm once ripped the term battling
cancer in the old days
a man could just get sick and die now
they have to wage a battle
[ __ ] this is one of those sites you got
to pay the [ __ ] just to read the [ __ ]
the local [ __ ] like [ __ ]
britney got gunned down at a popeyes and
i got to pay eight dollars to read it
but that's what it is
it was that cancer
the cancer dies when you die so
technically it's a draw
but man
i'm curious to see where he pops up in
the realm of existence next
you might see a sheep doing something
weird or you might see him
you might see this uh
i don't know
a moose
having quite a time and that could be
him
god bless you norah mcdonald man
you know and he did he kind of
disappeared out of the you know he did
that show with adam eget a lot of great
jim carrey moments from there and then
he kind of you didn't see him much but
uh one of a kind anyway i'll keep moving
here what else do we have here
um
here is a question right here that came
in this is a video question
hey theo
so far the aaa meetings and [ __ ] like
that hasn't related to me so much
your podcast is related to me far more
if you ever had any interest in
maybe starting somewhat of an aaa group
of your own maybe some of your
podcast listeners who could
just join with the zoo meeting or
something like that
just a random idea thrown out there
maybe there are more people like me gang
gang baby
gang brother thank you for that
suggestion man and um
[Music]
you know it's so funny that
that you say that because i i i was just
thinking the other day i was at a zoom i
went to a zoom a a meeting in new york
it was a new york one i think
sometimes it's fun you can get on there
some of them they don't have all the
passwords it's hard to get in but
sometimes you get in
you know
the other day a guy he's like i never
shared before in a meeting but i see my
boy theo in here i'm gonna share
you know made me feel nice obviously you
didn't
i mean it didn't
you know
it made me feel welcome we all just want
to feel welcome i think it's a thing
amongst
people that suffer from
or just people in general we all just
want to feel welcome in the world
and in a moment
you know i think a lot of us maybe had
moments when we were young where we
didn't feel welcome
in that moment
and i know that's a real particular and
kind of [ __ ] weak thing to say
but enough of those stack up and it can
really build up in you but the answer is
yeah man i just was thinking about that
the other day so that what a what a real
gift that you and i are on some sort of
same balance beam man and you're hitting
this idea i thought about that
what would it be like to have a zoom um
[Music]
i think when i'm able to keep some good
time together man i'll really look into
that uh
you know i'm working with a fourth step
right now and um
and i appreciate you asking though
brother i appreciate you thinking about
me man and i love you dude and good luck
on your journey too and if i do i'll uh
i hope i'll see you there
on the road to happy destiny fam what
else we got here
um hey theo so i'm watching a show
like i always do
thank you very much for watching young
lady homeward
like every night i've been watching for
like two or three years now
and i'm noticing
that
you don't really have no
black women on your show like i don't
think you've ever had a black woman on
either one of your shows actually
and
i'm scrolling through and it's like
everybody
but no black women
so
i'm trying to say no when i'm saying
nothing but you know what's up because
you got black girl fans too
uh thank you young lady for the question
that's a great question you know um
you're right
you're right i was just thinking about
this as
you're saying it um
the closest we've had to a black woman
is probably
donnell rollins dude honestly if i'm
real honest um
yeah i know we asked miss pat to come on
recently she didn't she did not want to
she doesn't live uh she was she was
living in atlanta so we weren't able to
get her
it's a good point
um
yeah i think i just don't run i don't
i'm not in a lot of circles where i see
a lot of black women but i think
i'll have to keep my eyes and ears open
more
and see if we can find some great guests
i know there are great guests out there
um
in l.a yeah i know there's some good
black female comedians i just got to get
out there and get them
you know uh
so
yeah i'll do what i can you know i don't
want to do it just because i feel like i
need like i don't like anything like
that that feels real forced and i know
you're not saying that
um
but i know a lot of amazing black women
so i'm sure i can find some
uh i can ask some of them
uh more fervently if they want to come
and join us
because yeah we need a little bit of
that freaking chocolate perspective boo
i feel like
so we could use it in here then we need
to spice this [ __ ] up
so i feel you thank you very much for
the question that's a good and fair
question
um
here's a good question actually
hey theo um and you look beautiful by
the way too damn i shouldn't have said
that but damn
my question would be my name is michael
my question would be what's up michael
thank you for calling brother thank you
for being alive today man on earth
do you relate more
closely to like black culture ethnic
culture
than caucasian american culture
um it seems like caucasian american
mixed breeds like yourself like myself
kind of was starting to get away from
those real crispy crunchy white white
folk
and so just kind of let me know what you
think man straight player keep it that
way all day
uh have a good one
gang thank you michael it's a good
question man you know i think at
different points in my life i've had
some different moments and experiences
oh
you know i always hated rich people
growing up
and i'm sorry if anybody's rich man
but
y'all were the enemy man you know i was
real
we were impoverished and
[Music]
and at that point when sometimes when
you're poor you're an underdog you gotta
have
somebody to fight it you got to have
somebody on the other end of that uh
that teeter-totter
you get this he's got to be somebody
over there
so i think that you know i think that i
think i was
angry at the rich man
and it was a lot of rich white people
you know where i was at
they didn't have anybody else really to
be rich
and my neighbors were poor white people
and poor black people so
i certainly associated more at that
point in my life with black culture
and i was in a group uh
i was in like a little gang we were
shitty real shitty gang but it was black
children
you know i used to i got tickled by a
black man one time
when i was bathing somewhere outside at
my friend's house
my friend devin who was black he still
is black
and um
[Music]
yeah so i think when i really had such
an underdog mentality the only underdog
at that time was it felt like in america
was black
in my area in louisiana was just black
and white
so anything that was like against the
rich
you know i remember being a jesse
jackson fan growing up
that kind of [ __ ]
um
now
things are more merged kind of now
so i don't know
sometime what coal i don't know if i
associate with a lot of
i think it's a little i tell i i
you know
i like a little bit of all of it
um
i also think blm during the blm movement
it made me kind of scare like
i felt like everybody was on the same
page we were all
feeling good about about stuff and
moving together as a group
sometimes during blm i felt like
oh black people don't or or not black
people because that's too general but
that blm the movement itself they don't
want to be a part of everyone they want
their own thing
um
so that made me feel like
unwelcome sometimes in black in some
black areas
or
or even just in my mind maybe just in my
mind maybe not actually
in in physical areas
but i'd always felt like we're all on
the same page and then some of the blm
stuff made was like
oh
this group once
it felt like a lot of people wanted
black supremacy i don't like any kind of
supremacy that's what i don't like
um
you know i never related with redneck
cult like and not saying redneck is why
i never related with any uh
i don't like any type of supremacy you
know any group that's ever like we're
the group we're going to be the
[ __ ] that man
because that's not that then you're
already off my books man because we all
we're you know i'm that beige bad boy
eventually i believe we it ends base
and i could be wrong sure yeah i'm
probably wrong dude i'm usually wrong
think about something
and i'm probably wrong about it dude
um
but
uh
but i also have to notice that man you
can't just
you know i
have to notice that maybe some black
people never feel right in a in
the culture that's here or that
maybe there's something about
the you know i don't know
maybe never thought that maybe some of
my black friends they don't feel that
way they they feel like they just live
in this total white world and it's
uncomfortable
i don't know
so i have thoughts like that too well
and some of it i think is just history
and it's time it's like you know it's
just some things it's like
so what i can do is just as a person is
be loving to my friends
you know no matter who they are um
which is what i try and do
that's what i try my best uh
you know no matter what culture or
whatever and try and learn it's hard
sometimes
you know i'm at the damn
uh
at this
salon yeah the body salon
massager lady gave me a damn moon cake
bruh
chinese snack and i was like damn all
right i didn't know if i'm supposed to
you know you're you know
do i jerk myself off now what do i you
know i'm saying i don't even know what
to do but
so there's a lot of stuff going on a lot
of wild stuff um
but i think it goes in phases man i know
that i have both in me that's for sure
you know i never i related so much when
i was growing up to black people because
i felt so
uh
unaccepted
and
but as an adult i don't know if i feel
feel more like white culture i just
i don't know it's a good question man
i think now i'm a little bit more of a
hodgepodge one culture i see a really a
lot of similarities for me and is a lot
of times is mexican culture
you know um
you know i see a lot of like faith-based
kind of and not who
mexican culture is really christian a
lot of times sometimes i think of faith
in a more of a
more of a spiritual sense but
but i know the lord is there
um
but yeah tight sense of families i don't
know i think my now my culture is more
like it could be any color
it could be any shade
i think the culture that i pull from now
is
i try to pull from one where people are
being loving and
you know i see a father like a father
and son came out to my show a couple
weeks ago and
man it just
in san diego
and just dude i'd have given anything to
have a moment like that with my son and
then i get to be there for their moment
and help be a part of their moment and
like damn
that's my culture
you know i see a cute little kid walk by
and his mom picks him up or something
and loves him
that kid could be black or damn puerto
rican that kid could be giraffe
and that's really the culture that i
feel the most now uh
i think
i think man it's a good question thank
you for asking brother and i think some
of it is
but culture i mean you know it's tough
because it's like you can't say some
stuff you say oh well i love basketball
and you'll have some black people like
what you can do black people don't just
play basketball well yeah i know that
but i love things that black people saw
i love some things that black people are
i just love something that black people
are good at that white people are good
at
i love some things that brazilian people
are good at
you know so i don't know that's a good
question man it's interesting but thanks
for letting me think with you man and
thanks for making me think
um
here's another call that came in man uh
oh i got to do these ads damn i'm gonna
go out of business
i want to let you know about keeps
keeps baby you want to keep your hair
well we all do
i work on mine all the time you know i'm
trying to keep these strands baby trying
to stay stranded baby
i'm
thinking about the upstairs right
well with keeps you can
fight hair loss
that's right
easier access to hair loss treatment
prescription medication delivered at
home online doctor consultation
two out of three men will experience
some form of hair loss by the time they
are 35
more than 50 million men in the us
suffer from male pattern boldness
low cost treatments start at just 10
dollars per month and keeps offers
generic versions as well
if you're ready to take action and
prevent hair loss go to keeps.com
theo to receive your first month of
treatment for free that's k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash t-h-e-o to get your first
month free keeps.com
theo it's simple stress-free way to keep
your hair
convenient virtual doctor consultations
and medications
delivered straight to your door every
three months
that's keeps keps dot com
slash theo
i want to let you know right now about
upstart
if you're carrying a credit balance
month after month it can feel like
you're in a never-ending cycle of debt
upstart can help you make that final
payment so you can get ahead
you know i carry debt for a while as a
child
hell i think i was damn born in debt
dude i remember
seeing somebody that was broke when i
was a kid i thought it was my dad
and it wasn't him just a broke mfr
if you dread looking at your credit card
statements you're not alone nope debt
can feel crippling but upstart can help
you on your path to financial freedom
whether it's paying off credit cards
consolidating high interest debit
or funding personal expenses
over half a million people have used
upstart to get one fixed monthly payment
find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com
t-h-e-o
that's upstart.com
theo yup upstart considers your income
and current employment to find you a
smarter rate for your loan
that's upstart.com
t-h-e-o loan amounts will be determined
based on your credit income and certain
other information provided in your loan
application there's so many good
questions
uh and things came in
um and i'm gonna get to more of them
next week i'm gonna answer one more here
and then we're gonna give a call to
my boy chad busby and i remember him
beautiful fella semi beautiful i don't
know i don't actually remember what it
looked like but uh
decent guy kind of quiet guy whispery
we're a real real whispery boy
you didn't know what you know
every time you talk to him
they keep playing hide and go seek you
know he's like
like damn you and
were you born in a library dude you
gotta louden up
but here's a call that came in
uh
what up the uh i'm just here listening
to your episode with arias fear
i heard you uh talking about how you
needed a break mentally and
you know you're kind of afraid to let
down your uh your viewers who are afraid
that your audience won't be here when
you come back
and i just want to let you know that uh
just hearing you say stuff like that
helps me out because today i had to uh
you know
i had to crawl out of work for
you know uh
being down just being depressed
so uh
you know never be afraid to take some
time work on yourself buddy
we'll love you and we'll be here when
you get back
thanks bro i appreciate you saying that
man that's sweet of you say bro nice
messaging
yeah i'm happy for you man for taking a
moment for yourself taking some time
yeah i don't know why that hit me connie
you know i think uh
i think ever since i was you know or
something you know i always i'm always
basing on like if i don't do
everything who whatever
there's always been something in me that
if i don't do
or if i don't behave a certain way or do
a certain thing then i'm not enough you
know
that if i don't work hard enough or i
don't try or i don't say the right like
if i don't do you know
that here's what it is that my value is
contingent upon
my output
and that my value is not contingent upon
solely the fact
that i
exist
and that i am me
so that i think is part of the reason
why
i have that thing where i just feel like
i have to just keep going you know
and i i'm recognizing that that's not a
that's a false
that's a false god
whatever that's a false god
because no real
yeah it's just not real
you know and i think that that a lot of
that comes when you don't feel like
and this is a little sappy man but this
is what i feel and i'm okay if you don't
like this kind of [ __ ] then that's fine
bro go watch football fam i'll be
watching later too but right now
i'm upstairs dawg and this is what i'm
doing
and i'm not ashamed of myself
um
but yeah it's like
if uh
that the value of who i am to you is
based on what i do and not who i am
or not
solely that i am
you know and that's like
you know i i dated a gal for a while and
i know and this is the only time i ever
felt different in my life about that
actually two times i dated a girl
recently a few years ago and i know she
loved me unconditionally
you know and
i took advantage of that some uh but i
know that she did
she loved me just because of who i just
because that i was
a person you know
and my brother you know i know my
brother loves me
just unconditionally you know
uh
and i'm not crying right now i'm [ __ ]
sweating out of my eyes because i'm
doing work fam that's why
you could lift all the weights you want
on the outside but my weight is inside
um
so
i'm proud of you man i'm proud of you
for calling i appreciate you recognizing
that in and saying that to me and
letting me know it's okay i appreciate
that
because some of it is just those old
stories that are in your head like oh
man if i don't try harder if i don't do
enough then i'm not then i'm not enough
and i'm not saying i've cured that in
myself but i'm saying that moments like
this at least help me recognize it
and remind me of it
because i'll recognize something
then i get so high on recognizing it
that i don't even do the work to try and
remember to take care of it or to to
direct to to see that it's a ghost that
is
that can
be real thick
i got to get my ghost real thin man
but you know what i've decided for
myself i'm gonna take january off
i'm gonna take january off
uh and i may take a week or two off
before then
um
now will i fully live up to that i might
tape some episodes in advance
uh
but
um
but in turn what i don't want you to
think if you listen to this podcast
every week
which i don't know why you would
but you continue to do so
what i don't want you to think
if i take a few weeks off that i don't
care about you
that's what i don't want you to think
because that's the inverse
of the whole conversation we're having
right now
i don't want you to think if i take a
few weeks off that i don't care about
you
because that's not the truth man gang
baby
all right
let's get out of this
let's step out of our emotions and thank
you bro and i'm proud of you man take
some time you know
[Music]
take the time you need for yourself man
i'll love you when you get back pam okay
[ __ ] bro praise god
all right let's get him on the horn man
and look a lot of other beautiful calls
came in one of the things i oh yeah i'm
stopping a little bit earlier i i feel
tons of stress in my body right now so
i'm gonna take a break
i also signed up for one of those things
where you mail your [ __ ] in or whatever
to africa or whatever and they check it
out or whatever
so i'm doing that
oh
yeah
so yeah there's like a company i don't
know what it's called
but
i'm weaning off my medications right now
i'm doing different things to try and
see what's going on with me
and i could just be burnt out
and then i realized i work so much when
i get home i work i open my laptop when
i i get on a plane on vacation open my
laptop
i work
you know i also have employees and i
want them to be able to keep working out
you know
i know if i miss a week they miss a week
but i'm human man i'm just being human
you know that
i gotta remember it too
all right guys right now we're going to
give a call to my boy old chad over
there
and he was really close with billy
conforto and
you know i remember billy he really
billy was a beautiful fellow man one of
the only homosexual men that ever stood
up for me
praise god bro
we miss you man he's upstairs dog
hello
what's up big dog
all right hey what's up man
can you hear me better now
yeah it hit a lot better now hey man bro
dude so what's going on y'all where
y'all living that in the tent
we're staying right where we got flooded
at
oh really
yeah we
threw some furniture out stuff we
staying on some old
sofas and all that waiting for fema to
try to help out damn man y'all indoors
are outdoors
we're indoors and saying we just got
electricity yesterday
oh yeah what's the first thing y'all did
when you got it
sure we we've been going across the
street they got a church because our
water was off too so we had to go bathe
on the side where the water came out on
the church oh that's a baptism right
there that you do
[Laughter]
you triple baptized now man you
certified you might be a pastor bro one
more bath you might be a pastor yeah
that's what i'm talking about i think
the holy ghost
oh man dude thank you so much for uh for
jumping on with me today man i just you
know everybody on the podcast man loves
billy man everybody loves billy comfort
so it misses him and
and misses him being alive man i just
want you to
can you share with me just a good billy
story or something
yeah which is sure
i'll listen to the one when y'all um you
were talking to billy's brother chucky
or whatever oh yeah no it's
yeah we all was talking about you and
billy used to go out and use my my name
my id oh yeah did we use your well
my idea i lost mine and billy was always
he used anybody's id
yeah he did anybody's name i think i got
a couple tickets stealing
dude we had fun man i remember
well the funny thing about billy bro was
he would like say if you were at
somebody's house bro you were at just
anybody's house you're at somebody's
house
when that when that other person went
out of the room he would always be like
bruh
i think [ __ ] danny likes me bruh
and i'm like
i'm like dude danny's nine years old
like danny doesn't
yeah he used to do that to me
he loved doing that [ __ ] he always he
loved people he always like trying to
create like a little mystery
well would you walk out to go use the
bathroom if you were in there he's like
you seen the way he's looking at yeah
yeah
like really
yeah dude yeah just ridiculous man
billy was funny bro and he was tough too
dude tell me he he used to be able to
fight right
yeah you know him and all
the the dementias they are boss no
i even did it for a little while but
they uh
they said you know they all passed away
huh
well yeah i know some of them did man
jimmy and ronnie that's what's his
cousins the
the fighters
and how they died
um i think it was into
drugs or whatever oh pills drugs huh
yeah
and billy hit an embankment huh
oh
yeah and then even deshawn you remember
sean was the one i was um oh yeah
deshawn was fine dawg
i was only friends with you because of
the sun
yeah she um she passed away too oh man
i'm sorry bro
damn yeah
i think you had asked her to one of your
dancers or whatever she was gonna go
instead of billy and her was gonna go
with you i'm sure
oh yeah oh billy tried to come to our
prom i remember that he'd be like
because billy loved dressing up and [ __ ]
he's like bro
that might have been it bro he was going
he was gonna find him with somebody yeah
dude billy was the most fun man what's
something that you miss about him
she probably everything out probably
pretty much his compassion right he may
have a heart for everybody in that race
yeah i don't know it's just it don't
matter who you are if you if you needed
something he'll help you out he'll give
you his laugh
yeah he would man he would give you one
of his legs bro if he had a [ __ ]
if he had a wooden leg he'd give you
that bit so you could row a boat
yeah didn't chase you with the one leg
he got
whatever
trying to take the dog people out
walking on one leg
bro he was bro he would take a wooden
arm off and train a [ __ ] pit bull to
bite on that [ __ ] man
remember when he would get the dogs to
jump up onto the roof
yeah but like sometimes he's um
hang on like a rope from a limb and he
had a dog jump up there and grab it and
it won't come down until it jumped that
rim off the
um
branch off that tree
oh dude he took a [ __ ] rain gutter
off a whole [ __ ] uh off a ranch style
home one time with those dogs i saw him
do it man
bro he was like the [ __ ] gay he was
kind of like the gay michael vick i
think
he was special bro how did you meet him
man so were you guys cousins or what was
that because i don't remember exactly
how you guys uh met each other
it was it was uh
strange i was with um deshaun was their
cousin and uh
me and design started dating in like
fourth grade
dang him bro
and she uh
she i guess we were together about
eight years as um so we all we
you know during through high school and
stuff we went together but we
got back together when i was like 19 and
stayed together until she passed
damn man i didn't know you guys were
together when she passed man i'm sorry
bro
was it kind of hard at the end where a
lot of people were dealing with
addiction over there
yeah i guess it's from
everybody was addicted to like pain
medicine i don't know when all them
people were going to doctors out here
and all that
oh yeah man well dude i remember billy
so billy set me up with this girl one
time did you work over there with us by
the uh restaurant
which one y'all was that the broken egg
or something no we work at this place
called chefs bro i don't even think they
had a kitchen in that [ __ ] dude i don't
know what we were selling bro damn y'all
serving tv dinners oh i think we just
broke people
dinner
i think
i don't know what we would
the more i think about i think we had a
freezer and a bunch of bus boys i don't
think anybody in that [ __ ] had a food
he was in the freezer you know dessert
like hold on
billy bring this tinky
dinner billy was so professional too bro
billy loved dressing up for work he was
he'd be like oh your order will be right
out sir he was always so professional
i was so i was too like i tried to do it
but i was so embarrassed like i was shy
like embarrassed to talk to people and
stuff start stuttering
like god damn billy's like yeah
yeah billy was a g at it man yeah
yeah i miss him man he loved those dogs
too bro and dude he here's what i didn't
like though
he had some crazy weed
so we get all gassed up dude we [ __ ]
high as [ __ ] and then those dogs would
start looking at me and i was he knew i
was scared of dogs
and he would be like he'd always say
[ __ ] like don't worry i'll protect you
and i'm like [ __ ] that's your dog and
your weed this whole thing is a set up
dog
[ __ ]
man they were staring at you oh them
dogs are everybody dude it was funny man
and dog
he has some beautiful dogs though man um
so where you at now you living by the
church what you gonna do man y'all still
y'all still struggling down there huh
a lot of people just starting to get
their electricity but
i'm just waiting on
i guess fema or something to do
something i can't really do nothing
dang man
well look man i just want to say man out
of my heart you know billy did so many
nice things for me man uh
you know he just he stood up for me
you know there was times he was like a
little bit of an older brother
he gave me steroids bro that i don't
even think we're any good but i [ __ ]
still lifted [ __ ] dude right
yep your phone's real choppy what is it
i don't know if it's still choppy now no
no it's not
all right see i remember when he was
y'all was doing those steroids and stuff
oh yeah boy we was downstairs we was
[ __ ] checked
and billy would always wear these blue
shorts he'd be like bro i can't go to
the gym man i can't find my blue shorts
dog get some other shores man
some short shorts for the guys to look
yeah
i think it was like some board shorts i
don't know what it was dude but he'd
always be like bro i think that guy over
there is looking at me
and it would be like a blind dude some
blind dude in a [ __ ] standing there
with a walking stick i'm like that
dude's [ __ ] blind bro
no
no he's not he's not yeah
oh dude so billy one time set me up with
a girl
so he gave me a soma pill he's like this
will help you relax right
dude i've never taken a [ __ ] soma
phil in my life right
so first off about nine minutes after he
gives it to me i take a right turn
and i took it about 30 yards after the
turn right
so i drove right into a [ __ ] ditch
right
yeah i know this the song was like what
muscle relaxer thing because he i was
with billy one time and he gave me like
he he told me to take like two of them
whatever he's like here take this i was
riding with him back from the doctor she
was going to the doctor and we i said
well i'm hungry bro so we stopped at a
taco bell and i guess the soul must make
you like shake or whatever
i got a taco supreme i went sit down i
guess when they kicked in i shook all
the supreme over they had nothing but
meatloaf
yeah
yeah you ever been so filled up you
shook the supreme off a taco bro
i'm like what's wrong
why am i shaking like come on they're
looking at you it's time to go like what
did you give me
damn dude you leave out of there with
you it looks like a dog that just got a
haircut on the table it's just toppings
look at cheese lettuce
i got a shell and the meat left
shook my whole supreme oh
damn avoid them so
dude the summers will take your supreme
baby
them [ __ ] make your [ __ ] lips wet
and they'll take you supreme so then
look what happened was bro so we
he still said bro you can't stand this
girl up dude you can't be you got to be
a gentleman bro i'm like stand this girl
up i said i can't stand up
he's like [ __ ] it bra i got you dawg so
we go do we go to this nightclub over
there in fat city right
right over there in metairie when you
get off the causeway we go over there
dude
escapes or kenny's key west
some [ __ ] hole dude it was dicey bro
there was a lot of people in there some
dude drinking cologne in the corner
nice
it had a boxing ring in the middle of
the club like dicey okay
but uh
so anyway billy walks i can't even stand
up dude i can't even stand up it's like
weekend at [ __ ] bernie dude he walks
me in there
he's like bro nobody will notice if we
play that song electric slide right he
puts that [ __ ] on the jukebox i'm like
what the [ __ ] dude
so fast forward anyway he's like dude
the girl shows up i can't even see her
that's how [ __ ] high i can't even see
her
she ends up being nice she gives me a
ride home across the calls way back to
uh
mandeville
bro
at some point i was so sick it's just me
and her she's driving my car back i
puked all over her
so
i get home in the morning
i come out to my car the whole inside is
filled with puke except for the space
where she had been sitting driving
and i don't know where she is bro
you've never seen a since i've never
seen her since dude
but damn billy always had an adventure
man
well she's crazy
that's a lot man well look man on behalf
of the podcast man we're gonna send you
500 bucks just to [ __ ] do put a
little jingle in the pocket over there
buy some [ __ ] dinner for your boy buy
some popeyes for your neighbor or
whatever um
and i just want to say man i love you
bro and i love billy man and and thanks
for jumping on a call today with me
yeah all right i love you too
i'll still keep in touch with you man
yeah 100 man i'll hit you up this week
or something if you need something hit
me up man uh
and then whenever i come home dude we
got to go catch up we raised some money
for billy i was telling we sold a bunch
of t-shirts we want to put a like a
bench at like a dog park or something
all right yeah when you come in town or
whatever just um
hit me up and i'll call me and you're
going to take a ride or do whatever you
want to do gang bro
all right chad be good dude we'll hit
you with uh we'll hit you guys up on
i'll have the producer hit you guys up
man and um and we'll talk to you later
on dude thanks again all right thank you
all right
peace man
we gotta find some pictures of belly man
that's what we gotta find
we gotta find some pictures we're gonna
get the dog bench built
we gotta do a little bit of work left so
but right now
i'm gonna take it easy man on the way
out uh we got a beautiful song right
here
and this is uh
by evan bartels
off of his new album lonesome and we'll
put the link in there and
man he's played some beautiful hits for
us he's playing tonight somewhere i want
to go see it i'm
but we're leaving out tomorrow for
charlotte
uh
but this song
i i saw him play it early played it for
me when i came when i first like i think
my first night
that i had spent uh when i was in out
here in the central east he played
and i went and saw him
and uh
man
talent everywhere this is false gods by
evan
bartels you guys be good to yourselves
man and thank you for being a part of my
life
and uh
be good to yourself you deserve it okay
god bless america
i hope that's
what i'm true
online
[Music]
what i see on the news
looks like a war
[Music]
dogs out for
[Applause]
[Music]
kings
man it's funny and i hate to interrupt
you evan i mean you think i've talked
for an hour and a half you think i would
let you have your moment
but i think you just encapsulated what i
was thinking earlier man
when it comes to race or color or
i mean i think i'll always probably hate
rich people bro to be honest dawg
100 percent bro 200 probably
but yeah i think now i the thing that i
want to see
in people
is to love them i think because they're
human bro
let that be the deciding factor let's
cruise back in i'm sorry that wasn't
real
but you just hit it on the head man
that's what you do
if you want to feel something you listen
to some evan bartels man
and he's the ironic thing is he's also
does contracting and construction
but you want to feel him hit him on the
head
you want to feel him hit it on the head
the hammer is
is his music man
[Music]
you're human
and we can only free
on love because you're human
[Music]
what if it's true
is
then why are we here
what does it mean to be human
i would not bow my head
a lovely
there is no us
versus them
there is just you
in me
we're born we live we die
and i have to believe
that we can make it better
that we can only
three
i
[Music]
we're just humans
that is evan bartels off his new album
lonesome we'll put a link and we'll
support it more moving forward uh
yes
that's a real place to live man loving
people because they're human man that's
really
it feels like a lot of the only answer i
think
i want to thank um
sean dugan our producer i want to thank
spencer leato uh
our editor i want to thank colin reiner
our associate producer riley mao
couldn't be here
he's probably at some
camp for people that want to jerk off to
be honest with you
but we'll see if we can get him back in
soon uh
you gotta be good man